[MYSTERIOUS MUSIC]
[BABY CRYING]
In six, we wanted to show how
each of the family members
were equally culpable for what
happened in the past event.
It wasn't just Dorothy.
How was Sean responsible for
what happened to the child?
You learn in these flashbacks
that he should have been there.
And he feels really,
really guilty about it.
And it's driving part of his
learning about the cult.
Explain it to me.
I know, she's special and you.
But I don't understand.
So please, tell me.
I mean, it's definitely a
supernatural thriller.
But as grounded as we can
make the supernatural part
is the trick so it doesn't
crack and it becomes ruleless.
We want it to have rules.
What was he saying about me?
He said we have to return
you to where we found you.
He said you're needed there, so--
And you believe him?
I don't know what I believe.
For example, in this episode, we're
meant to learn what the
ramifications are
of Leanne's actions.
There's a little bit of Leanne
taking on the personality
of the Turners' lives.
And the house itself is
taking on the presence
of her being in this home.
She caused this.
Some of it's cracking.
Some of it's changing.
And I think we can all
connect with the idea
that maybe there's something
out there that we don't understand,
the unknown that we can't make sense of.
[SCURRYING NOISE]